نزعه مائم الملل في الشوارع صور يتداولها
النشطاء في ايران بكثافه
حاله جديده يطلقها المحتاجون الايرانيون
للتعبير عن غضبهم ورفضهم للعلماء المسلمين
الذين يمثلون في نظارهم السلطه القمعيه
والعنيفه والمتطرفه
بعد نزع الحجاب وحرقه في الاماكن العامه
تتخذ الاحتجاجات في ايران اشكالا مختلفه
في مواجهه قمع المظاهرات من بينها تحطيم
الحواجز الفاصله بين الذكور والاناث في
الجامعات
والمقاطعه السلع الاستهلاكيه التي تحتكرها
الحكومه باستثناء المواد الغذائيه
في الشارع حيث تتواجد قوات الامن بكثافه
غالبيه هذه الملابس المدنيه
تسارعت على اثرها السلطات الى قمع
الاحتجاجات فردت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بفرض المزيد من العقوبات
[موسيقى]